il ya nous sommes ce soir à meursault
dans une cave comme il y en a beaucoup
dans la région et pour une manifestation
ma foi qui s'avère fort sympathique
bien sûr on déguste beaucoup de vin je
crois que la particularité de cette
soirée c'est que les invités de marque
sont ici s'agit de bourvil et de louis
de funès qui tourne actuellement comme
vous le savez la grande vadrouille à
meursault sous la direction de gérard
hook
mais je m'approche maintenant de louis
de funès et bourvil sont en train de
parler ensemble ce que nous dire quelque
chose de drôle pas du tout rire tr/min
vous étiez fan roulement de trouver ce
petit baala mais c'est un jeu c'est un
beaujolais
oui mais comment vous le trouvez vous
êtes sûr c'est un beau chalet dans mon
verre parce que je suis je suis lucide
je mens trop de ce vin là est un mauvais
alors je me trouve dans pour moi c'est
simple est soudé
et oui lettrines est ce qu'ils vont nous
trouver ce très bon excellent excellent
pas du tout vous connaissez pas du tout
je sais écouter le bon vin quand même
dit vous avez terminé le film la grande
vadrouille avec jean-louis enfin vous le
terminé par mais vous le terminer à
meursault quels souvenirs vous allez
emporté de la bourgogne et plus
particulièrement de ses petits poings de
morceaux de bonne coupe du monde
rapporte que j'ai commander du vin n'est
pas là j'ai déjà des souvenirs c'est
pareil on a commandé du grenelle
c'était déjà lui